okay let's go
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen welcome back to
your favorite podcast
[Music]
you know the name
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to griffin
with griffin
the solo train just keeps rolling i got
a lot to talk about this week
one of mythbuster bidets of course
lebron james winning the championship
[ __ ] boys and some other stuff like that
and some more real world advice from a
grown ass man so
i'm glad you guys are back here again
every week we're going strong and i
really appreciate the support i
appreciate the love and you know just
once again thank y'all for listening
yeah just straight off the bat right off
the rip yesterday
lebron james wins his fourth title ten
trips to the championship
um dope right i'm listening i'm a
clippers fan y'all know i'm a cleverest
fan of the other
i would love to have seen the clippers
versus the lakers
even if the lakers would have went on to
to the championship i would have liked
to have seen
you know the lakers play the clippers to
go to the championship so
kind of anticlimactic that way we didn't
get the the the series
that we wanted maybe that we deserved in
the pandemic
we didn't get that so is what it is
but i just want to take a little time to
talk about lebron james talk about the
nba i love
i love the nba like i said i'm a
clippers fan but i've always been a
lebron james fan
and i liked it anybody um that could be
as great as what
i saw in my childhood which was michael
jordan michael jordan was one of the
greatest players
he is the greatest player ever to play
uh i got to see that i got to live
through that
you know i got to see him defeat the
pistons and
beat magic in the finals and we just we
dealt with all those things you know
imagine getting hiv and that changing
the course of like oh maybe that would
have been a great rivalry and
we never got to see that so there's a
lot of disappointments along the way but
just watching jordan through his whole
career was great
and then you're trying to see who can
replace that then we saw some great
um laker teams like when shaq and kobe
and then that pistons team and then
houston and you know we saw a lot of
great teams go through this but just the
players
you know when you think about great
players you think about the standard of
excellence
michael jordan is just at the top you
know but you know you can make a case
for lebron james
if somebody wants to make a case that
they think lebron james is the greatest
player ever i'll listen
and you know you're going to have a
great argument at the end of it you
might be like okay you know what we're
we're we
um agree to disagree there's only a few
players in history that can even be in a
conversation like that where two sides
can be like
all right you know what you made a good
point or hey i'm never i'm not gonna
agree with you
but just as a consensus there's no other
players to to come in there there's
players that get close like kareem
[Music]
even kobe bryant uh is somebody that
somebody might say that but you know
when you look at the stats you look at
the numbers you look at the
the longevity of the career the standard
of you know how great people were at a
certain time
you know then you start to go well maybe
that person is not in there you know so
it's
it's uh it's tough so you know you get
you know we got lebron having
three championships with three different
teams multiple times to the championship
with
you know well with two of the teams and
we'll see what happens
so i mean the real question is if lebron
james first of all let's just talk about
this dude he's a physical specimen like
anything we've ever nothing we've ever
seen like that in the nba ever
to be like six nine um
to be that built to take care of himself
the way
he has um to be that fast
that strong to be able to jump that high
just just
there's so many things about the dude
makes him just like probably the most
physically gifted
athlete you know sp basketball player
for sure
because you look at michael jordan
michael jordan was a great friend he had
a great frame he was six
six and he was fast and he could jump
out the gym right
dude lebron probably can jump higher is
stronger
taller as fast if not faster
bigger i mean you know what i mean max
kellerman on first take always says that
if
magic and lebron if magic and jordan had
a baby it would be lebron james and i
totally with that now when you think
about jordan you know he had this kind
of killer mentality from the beginning
of his career so we never got to see
like
the growth we saw on michael jordan was
the growth of somebody uh understanding
how to be a team player but that killer
instinct that will to want to win and be
the reason why you win
it was always there for for the majority
of his career 90
of his career maybe even 95 of his
career so
that's been the knock on lebron james
even though when you look at the numbers
you go to one of these stat sites and
you look at like
last second shots you look at
game-winning shots you look at
most points in the last minutes of the
game lebron's right there with anybody
in history so
you know this is just kind of like a
perceived knock on him but
but we've seen some things in him and so
the first part of his career even though
he when he went to the championship
against san antonio
he like miraculously got that team to
the championship he was overmatched
you know he didn't have the team to go
with his talent
but he still didn't have that thing how
can i take over how can i be the man
uh you know that killer instinct it
didn't seem that he had that
and then so that was the knock then he
goes to miami they lose to dallas where
he
really wasn't the player that he is
today even though he was in his physical
prime
and then the next year they figured it
out they won two championships
um the moment for me that lebron james
changed
from just a dude where you were
questioning if he had the killer
instinct was
i think it was game five or game
six against it was game six against
boston they were down
three two and he was in the layup lines
before the game and he had this look on
his face like
something's up with this dude it was the
kind of look where he was like are we
not losing this game we shouldn't even
be in this situation
and he had like 45 points that night
couldn't miss was all over the place i
think he almost had a triple-double i
don't remember the stat line of that
game but
it was incredible and that was that
changed him
they won the championship they won back
to back and then
i felt like the front office failed
lebron james and miami for that
fourth year they didn't sign the pieces
they needed they didn't spend the money
and they suffered
they went up against a a team with you
know and they should have lost
the year before that that second
championship kawhi leonard's at the free
the line
they're up three he misses one
yeah they're up three they're up two
what was it yeah they were up
two he misses a free throw then he makes
the second which puts him up three
he makes both those free throw they go
up four they win the championship
okay so you know people like to forget
that and then ray allen comes down he
hits the three
then they go they win that game and then
they go
win game seven but like kawhi leonard
had a chance to
take him out and he didn't anyways so
that was the moment i thought that
lebron james worked up to be the player
that he is now and then all through the
the cleveland years just unfortunate
that he had to go up against a 73-win
team that added a generational talent
just weak
that was just weak you know so but even
we still thought that don't we still
thought
can cleveland beat golden state warriors
and the only reason we thought that is
because of how great lebron james is
and then now throughout his time where
his his physical prime is gone
i feel like the mental and eye of the
tiger and killer instinct it's all there
it's just
we just wanted to see it maybe 10 years
earlier but we got it now we should
enjoy it
so i feel like you know i feel like they
won this championship
doesn't have an asterisk is the question
people are going to ask and you know
i don't know you know i'm not i didn't
play nba basketball so i don't know like
what the differences are
but like with our eye test it looked the
same to me
you know but is that is that traveling
and having home court and
all the things that go into making uh
you know
the nba great that stuff was missing
uh and but it compensated by okay now
they're there they're away from their
families
uh they're then quarantined they have to
there's nobody in the gym to cheer them
on except for themselves so i mean you
know
does it is it equivalent you know so i
don't know this might have asterisks buy
it but it's still a championship when
it's all said and done
you know you're gonna look back and be
like oh remember that pandemic
championship
but it's still on a red like if it was
his only championship then you'd be like
oh man that sucks but the dude already
got three so this is a four
now if the world starts to get back to
normal and they're talking about having
fans in the stands
and let's say the lakers go back and get
another championship or at least go to
it and then maybe they get another one
but i feel like if he gets back to back
or even gets a three-peat
man you're talking about six titles
in 12 years that's 50 in the finals but
12
finals appearances if he gets something
there if he gets five
six championships and he has to get him
now because of his age
and then like you know you got anthony
davis ascending into this really
fantastic defensive offensive all-around
basketball player
you know you're talking about really a
serious
it's even more serious because to me i
feel like lebron always got it he
already has a case
he already got a case to be like i'm the
greatest player of all time he's got a
case for it already all right
so you add two more championships
with a you know this is a third
franchise i don't know
i think you you're right there with it
so it's a shame you know i just
how the pandemic affects uh how the
pandemic has affect our world and
you know every single day i mean it's so
it's so
bizarre you know we keep saying the new
normal i guess eventually we got to just
start saying
it's the normal you know it's craziness
right so i just
man i wanted my clippers to get there
you know the clippers they fired dog
rivers so i knew they cared about it
because if they didn't care about it
they wouldn't fire dark rivers but
maybe next year i don't know what it's
going to look like but it's crazy that
the season started in october of last
year and we're now in october so it's
been the nba season has gone a
full year like it's already supposed to
have been started already so
like this is going to change the
schedule like how long is this going to
affect the schedule like
you know when will it get back to normal
are they going to take time off like
what are they gonna do like it's
so bizarre man so but again are we gonna
say
new normal or is just gonna be normal so
probably just it's gonna be
this is our normal and so hopefully we
can figure it out you know and then
here we got this election coming up and
i don't know what's going to happen but
i hope people vote
you know let me just put that message
out there right now through the podcast
please vote
i don't care who you want to vote for
you know i get a lot of people they
think they're trolling by you know
vote i'm voting for trump if you want to
vote for trump vote for trump go out
there and vote
man that's all you got to do uh whoever
you are i
i i don't i'm not going to talk about
who i'm going to vote for or why i'm
going to vote for a person but
i'm registered to vote i'm going to vote
i haven't always done that in the past
but
i feel like we're so divided in this we
need to galvanize somehow so
whoever it is let's get a great voter
turnout so then we can look at this and
be like all right this is great results
we have enough sample size of people
voting to be like all right this has
affected electoral college in certain
way
so now we know we feel solid about this
but
the voter turnout was so low in 2016
way lower than it was in uh the obama's
uh first election
that you know it's like it's hard to go
where is everybody why aren't you voting
now why don't you care
it could have been different you know
like the people that are anti-trump you
get to understand that it could have
been different if you would have went
out and voted
but you didn't so we just kind of like
sitting around like because we think you
know what it is we have too much faith
in the system
you know we're sitting here like oh well
a real politician will get in there
we'll
just we'll even if we don't like that
person at least
the government's going to run us
smoothly a certain way well i guess you
were wrong you know
i guess no you really need to pay
attention and make sure that you
that you do your part to know that you
tried to put the the candidate that you
wanted in there
notice how i didn't say the right
candidate just just
let's go through the system properly so
but anyways i got on a tangent with that
so
nba congratulations to lebron james and
the lakers
i'm l.a born and raised so i'm still i'm
a la fan so i like to see when the
championships here in l.a
just a shame there won't be a parade
maybe there'll be some kind of virtual
parade
you know maybe just the lakers just have
their iphones they just drive around the
streets
being like oh we all parade so we'll
we'll see what happens with that
all right that's all my lakers talk i
want to talk about you know some people
i say you should i should do an mba
podcast but there's so many like youtube
channels that do mba stuff i don't know
i love the nba i think it's a it's one
of the best sports to watch
on tv and live use it's hard to say that
about some of the other sports
hockey's great live not good on tv
football is great
on tv but it's different like it's not
the same experience live like completely
different live i don't know if you've
ever been to an nfl football game but
that [ __ ] is not the same
it all depends on where you're seating i
remember one year i was in washington
and i went to go see the washington team
um and i was and i got these tickets it
was only a hundred dollars
i just got one ticket because i was by
myself so i got this one ticket and i
was sitting at the
i saw the ticket i was like a hundred
dollars sitting at the 50-yard line it
was washington vs detroit
uh so anyway i'm sitting at the 50-yard
line
like sort of ground level right and i
was like oh my god but then when i got
to the scene i was like wait a minute
you know you can't really see anything
and then like you have to look at the
game where you're moving your head
side to side you know your players are
in the way
uh you don't get that experience of like
seeing the field and seeing plays
uh happen like you do on tv and then you
know football's about fantasy sports and
stuff too so you're checking your stats
and
it's it's a kind of like at-home
experience you know uh
it just works better at home when you
got your your crunching your numbers
with you but i don't know
just basketball is one of those sports
that when you're in the gym you still
get that feel of like
whoa this is dope you know depending on
where you're sitting even when you're
because if you're sitting up top
just looks like oh you get to see the
whole court you see everything if you're
sitting down
lower then you're really getting that
experience of seeing a player so the nba
is just really a fantastic sport and i
love it and so i always
always ride or die for the nba i had a
few things i wanted to talk about
on this episode one of them is i want a
myth so i got a bidet
i don't know i have a tushy it's called
a tushy you know
i got this thing you attach it to the
toilet and then you know it sprays
water you know to like
flush your booty you know your butthole
or whatever i don't know what's the
proper term
all right so you get this bidet so i
attach it it's dope
okay i'm like oh this is exciting i
always hear about this because you
always think like a day is for rich
people
or you at a fancy hotel but this ain't
like the ones at the hotel because those
are weird to me because it's almost like
a separate toilet
which i don't understand why you want to
you're already sitting down you dirty
now you got to get up from this spot and
move over to another spot to like
clean yourself off it's it's i never
like that just weird to me
it's just weird that that that foot that
two foot trip to the other area
you just feel like you you spilling
stuff it just feels dirty
okay so you get you so you did these
things they have now you attach it to
your toilet you have a little knob
all right so the knob i don't even know
if i've talked about this already but
i don't care i'm doing it again so you
have this knob you know what i mean
and then like if you turn it so like
this way the water flushes into the
toilet so you can clean it and flush it
out
the other way is the one that sprays up
and it attacks your butthole
all right so they got the knob has like
cut it in half and they have different
slots okay
of pressure level so let's say it goes
to ten
all right you know so one two three four
five six seven nine ten
you have like ten sort of like dials
they have it does it's like it's it
feels like it has ten dials
right at two
you could take paint off a battleship
okay
i don't understand who needs the dial to
be
turned i almost i almost
cut a hole through my body because i
thought oh
this feels i need to turn this on and
the thing sprayed up almost killed me
it's just so i don't understand who is
using that
pressure like literally like click
you're like whoa
and then one more click and you're like
ow so
i got display i got i got into a groove
i got it figured out but anyway you see
the commercials about the days
and they always talk about you don't
need to use toilet paper this is the
myth i want to bust like
or you just use it to just because it's
going to be wet so you're using it to
dry off nah man let me let you know
right now
it don't clean you the way they claim
okay if you just using a bidet
and you're just air drying you dirty
all right that bidet is just
okay maybe it you know just think of
like a car covered in dirt
and you got a water hose and you're
going to spray it takes a lot of water
to get that dirt off your car
and you still got to get in there and
buff so
make sure you don't don't think that if
you get a bidet that oh man i'm gonna be
saving so much money on toilet paper nah
you still gonna be using toilet paper
almost the same way
um yeah so that's my myth busting on
that okay because it for sure needs to
be myth busted
but they don't clean you the way they
claim maybe i got the cheap one i don't
know
but i don't think so because i've been
in other places and i've seen the same
thing with the dials
so make sure um you still and i still
have like little booty wipes
i make sure i'm lemony fresh when i'm
done listen let's let's move on from
this
because this is just it's too much
but anyways i wanted to talk about that
okay so i had this
one um well first of all before i even
go in there i want to talk about like
uh critics i saw um chappelle
give his acceptance speech for his i
think it was an emmy he won for his uh
sticks and stones
great special but you know when it first
came out he got a lot of flack it was
like all these critics were
painted it was like god this is terrible
even though like
you i thought it was like rotten
tomatoes or something it was like like
over 90
users loved it and then the critics were
like some low number
but i started to think to myself what do
we need critics for in this day and age
what is a critic like who are they what
do they do
you know if i had to look up like if i
looked up like let's just look up right
now
if i if i looked up um in google
what is a critic okay
like what what would it say a person who
expresses an unfavorable opinion of
something
a person who judges the merits of a
literary artistic or musical works
especially
one who does so professionally so
they're just a professional
[ __ ] talker you know you see that a
person who expresses an
unfavorable opinion so you got critics
to do
so that's it there's nothing more than
that
so who are critics why do we need them
now when i was a kid i used to watch
siskel and ebert that was the thumbs up
thumbs down guys
and the thing about it though is you
know there was an internet okay so
maybe you had the newspapers so there
wasn't really this math
way to find out about things so you
trusted the critics
you go and then you go why is this guy
critic oh he's been writing for 25 years
at this particular paper in the
entertainment section he went to film
school or he did that
so you kind of got you this person has a
resume
a history of things about them that you
go oh okay this is why i trust this
person's opinion
then they had this you know thumbs up
this uh cisco the movie review show with
cisco and ebert
and then they would um you you kind of
started to get to know them
you kind of got to know their
sensibility and you would go all right
you know i
when they say to watch a movie maybe
i'll watch a movie or if one of them
would be like they didn't like the movie
i kind of knew i was like i don't always
agree with him so i'm gonna go see this
movie because i don't think he's right
but either way you got a sense of who
they are
and what they were about so that made it
like that's why you trusted them
you trusted them or you didn't trust
them because you got a sense of who they
are by the things they wrote and the
things they said on television
all right so now cut to we're in the age
of the internet so i don't need to rely
on two guys
or uh seven or eight critics around the
country to know if i like something or
not
because i can i can get a sense from the
people
you know something like rotten tomatoes
you know you're going to say hey what
i wonder what movies came out last week
and let me see if people liked it or not
why are you looking at critics why you
look at these seven artsy
pretentious people when you can look and
see a hundred thousand people saw this
movie
and they rated it on this website so a
hundred thousand people were like oh i
thought
they thought it was pretty good to me
that's a better indication of if i'm
gonna be entertained at this movie
than these critics and then you start to
look at some of the critics and you go
who are they who are these people
av club is like that just a couple of
nerds sometimes just
trash and stuff and then you go to that
person's
instagram and you go oh they got like
100 followers
so like what credibility does this
person are these some of these people at
somebody and not just them just saying
it anywhere
what is the credibility that they have
we don't even know who they are
you know you go to the you know when you
go on a website it might be whatever and
it goes here's the author here's their
twitter
start going to these people's twitters
and you'll start seeing like well damn
who's following you and like what are
some of the things you're saying
regularly on your twitter i don't even
know who you are
who are you to be who are you to be the
authority
on things that are good or bad i just
think it's a profession
that we don't really need anymore
because like i said
we have enough people on the internet to
get a sense
at you know by what's going on i don't
know
um people that are actually in the
business it's hard we don't
they they don't want to be critiquing
each other but that to me would be a
better
indication of if something's good or not
and you talk to active actors or some
like some actors are really serious
they're really pretentious
and they're you know so they want like
the oscars
and those type of award shows they want
to feel like
there is some sort of artistic critique
uh
particular criterium for why
criteria i was [ __ ] am i saying a
word right whatever you guys get it
they they want to know that there's a
particular thing that these people
are um following you know what i mean
to make sure that um it's
you know they go okay well this person
is you know it's like the foreign press
they're like
who are they those people right but who
are they are they following a certain
are they following a certain thing to
make sure that
the people that they got for this you
know
are they can we trust them can we trust
these people's opinions
you know can we trust like oh when they
say something's good and they go well i
think this person says it's good because
of the integrity of this person's
background and
how do we know like how do we know
there's so many sites and so many people
just
talking to vulture and and all these
places we go who are these people
writing these things
i don't know them i wish that they would
you know you
you need to go to twitter and find out
oh well this you know they're they're
actually not that interesting
so why are we so because a website or a
place has said okay you're going to be
in charge of
bashing television shows why are we
listening to that one person
when we have the ability to listen to
countless people
to to test things out you know if like a
show comes out and we go all right
a hundred thousand people or you know 15
million people like this show
uh let's let's let's have some random
surveys go out tell me why you like this
show
i think that that would be a better
indication of like if it's good or not
you know but i guess some artsy people
feel like ah well
it won't that people are dumb and you
know then it would be like fast and
furious would win every
year well maybe it should i don't know
i get it though as an actor myself i
understand that you want things that
have
put the craft together in the right way
so that's why i like the oscars because
the oscars is voted on by the people
that are in the industry because
you know it's like i like to know that
lighting people are
are being involved in why the the
best award went to this particular thing
for lighting
because all the lighting people were
like oh they recognize what it is
same thing with acting same thing with
any of the things that go on in the um
in those award shows but like but for
like
just random critics and newspapers and
websites
who are they to be to to have such a
powerful voice
not to say that it's even powerful but
you know sometimes it is
you know you got like i don't understand
from my show i'm dying up here that i
was on and we got canceled for many
reasons but
part of the reason was it just didn't
get a critical acclaim
even though to this day we've been off
the air three years
literally every single day somebody is
sending me a message like oh i just saw
this now it's on
prime you can watch them down in here up
here on prime and they're like this is
such a good show i can't believe they
canceled it and i go
well where were these people when it was
time to like
uh you know make an assessment of the
show so i don't know
i feel like chappelle he was he was
bitter i could tell he was like that was
really like a [ __ ] you you know it was
great you know like hey
you know you know this was a teachable
moment for you critics
you were wrong you know it was like a
real that energy was like
and i saw an article kind of like
bashing him now there's some article
saying like you know
oh this is because he's old you know
this is a guy in the 40s doesn't know
how to take credit
you know so they just keep this just
going back and forth but
you just go i just really want to know
like what is the point of critics
i'd love to see that discussion in the
in the notes there in the comments
uh even if you want to send me messages
on instagram like you know what is the
purpose of critics why
why why do we still have them in a day
and age where there's so much internet
so much accessibility to do so many
other things so you guys tell me you
know let me know what you guys think
all right where are we at now
um all right did that okay so
i got this message i got this message
from someone
uh from my real ass grown ass man advice
uh section you know and i'm
it's this is not necessarily because i
already i already sort of answered it
so i didn't want to i didn't want to use
this one but i did want to talk about it
like this guy says
i'm in love with two different girls and
i don't know how to choose this love
triangle sucks
so i wrote him back and i was like does
it suck bro does it
uh nah man you suck you're being a
selfish mofo i think you
i think you love the thrill of having
two girls more than you love either of
them you're having
fun now but it's not going to end well i
mean that will blow up in his face
you know and it was great i got this
message from
i've gotten like some messages uh from
girls
who are like this one girl said let me
find it oh she says
in the name of females around the globe
thanks for telling [ __ ] boys that they
suck
you know someone made me think though i
was like hey let's talk about
this let's talk about the f boys um
you get dinged for saying the f word too
much so we'll call them the f boys now
you know what the problem is like people
don't take responsibility for the
creation of this
for the creation of like i love
listening to girls i love because rachel
listens to these girl podcasts where all
the girls
talk like this hey guys what's up
i don't know what's going on today my
hair and i
don't know they all talk like that it's
so annoying
anyway but they all talk about f boys
all the time oh there so
here's a problem you support them
the problem you all have with [ __ ] boys
is
that's the ones you want you want to be
with them
and you're mad they're not conforming to
what you think
they should be doing you know there's
plenty of
guys out there there's plenty of good
guys out there there's plenty but nah
they're not those guys they're not those
guys
they're attractive there's late they're
ladies men there's they're they're
they're
macho chauvinistic they're like you know
they got a lot of women in the stall
and y'all are one of them and you're mad
but you're
are you surprised like are you really
shocked that
a dude that has like so many options
is taking advantage of them and like you
feel like you got got
the problem is the level that the
the minimal level of you feeling special
you need to raise that that's to me
is the problem whatever basic level you
go
well let me give you an example real
world example
so my buddy you know my friend krista
leah he's gone through all this stuff
he's had all these allegations against
him
and then there's just people that are
coming out with stories about him
i don't condone bad behavior i think
chris uh
you know he was he's a chauvinist okay
he was a ladies man he loved being with
ladies and
he let it get out of hand all right but
that being said
some of these girls like they they
wanted to be with him
okay he he he's they want you they
wanted him so they they pursued him
so anyways my point is i saw this one
story on one of these things where the
girl's
talking about him and she says i he made
me
feel special uh
and i drove from texas to california to
see him
what hold on
at what point did you feel special
on the 10-hour drive from texas to
california
so whatever attention he was giving
that made you feel special enough to get
in the car
and drive
that's let me tell you let me tell you
the special one
she getting flown out okay and check
this out
even that one ain't special because he
gonna use miles
because he travels a lot you know what
i'm saying like
what level what does it take for you to
be like oh i feel special
because this person i'm enamored with is
giving me attention
and so that attention is enough to make
you feel like well now i'm the one
or now well he's going to treat me
better no i just feel like you know
that's not enough and that's regular
guys are over here watching the
the the alpha male attractive ruggedly
handsome guy
get all the women and we're like yeah
we're over here too but you ain't
looking at us
you ain't looking at us you too busy
trying to chase after ryan gosling and
those type guys
you don't that's the guy you want okay
but you're not you don't you
you don't think he look it's like a deli
he looking around
uh number 78 number 78.
then and you're shocked so raise the
level
of what you want to feel
have more have a better standard of
these are the things that make me feel
special that i know this
person is there for me before you go out
of your way
to just jump into bed with the guy or
know what it is
you know know what it is just just own
it
you're attracted to [ __ ] boys it's just
it's on that
it ain't his fault okay he doing him
you attracted to that it's just weird
you know
and that's just like by the way too i'm
currently getting tired of this attack
on male comedians
as if we're all the same i've heard this
statement
so many times from some females who are
saying like
you male comedians are
using your you use your fame you use
your whatever that is you know you use
your fame
to that you want to use the words pray
but i'm gonna say
we use the fame to get with women and my
question to them is
where is the fat bald dude
with no options that you're having sex
with where's he is he
is he living in your guest room because
you know you're you know you're going
for all types of men
yeah where's that guy where's he uh
where's the dude living with his mom and
no job uh is he
is he with you are you having sex with
him are you going out on dates with him
are you attracted to that guy
nah [ __ ] you're not you attracted to
the same guy that you're trashing you're
attracted to that type of guy
because that's the guy you're always
with now here's my problem with it
it implies that only dudes
who are born pretty and handsome
and attractive they're the only ones
allowed
to get with beautiful women they're the
only ones allowed
the rest of us just have to be like well
we weren't born with anything so now we
have to just sit back and watch the
pretty people do their thing
nah me
becoming who i am
getting my career in gear having
confidence in myself
that should not be looked at as a
negative that's part of
the arsenal that's part of
that's part of positive those
those are the positive things about me
i've used
my talent and made that attractive
there ain't nothing wrong with that
that's part of it now yes
uh being inappropriate or being you know
what i'm saying like that's
different how you take these tools that
you have and how you apply them
you can judge that you could be like hey
you know you're talking to 10 people
you're saying all the same things or
you're sleeping with five different
people at the same time and you're
claiming things
that they're your girlfriend you're not
i mean you understand what i'm saying
but the actual
tools that i have put into play there
ain't nothing wrong with that
that's part of who i am that's that
that's my
equivalent to my being born pretty hey i
was born
funny there's a reason why people come
watch me perform there's a reason why
i got acting jobs those talents and all
that stuff that goes into why people
find me attractive and i'm tired of
people making it out like
that's a bad thing it's especially when
they turning around
and they trying to sleep with athletes
and and ufc fighters
those people who are trying to you know
when you're doing that kind of stuff
when you're out there doing that don't
don't don't come at me
talking about you male comics yeah
yeah yeah yeah that was part of it you
know she but
should we should some of us have been
more respectful and all that stuff that
if you want to talk about that you can
but you ain't gonna make me feel like
i'm supposed to just sit by and do
nothing because
i i'm not you know aesthetically as
pleasing as
some uh some hot guy you know the guy
that just he's just hot
so that means oh well he's the only one
allowed to be with hot people
now shut up that's what i say to you
shut up
zero [ __ ] like i care about that right
now i'm i'm tired of it
i'm tired of it let's talk about what we
actually need to talk about
stop putting male comics all in the same
boat
especially the ones of color okay hey
i had to bust my ass to get where i'm at
they didn't just go he's a male boom nah
man
it didn't work like that i had to fight
through a lot of stuff
and you need to take a look at these
lineups these lineups for the past five
six years when all this stuff was going
on they still
mostly white okay it's still
mostly white so when the white female
comics
are trying to act like all male
comedians when they say that
nah you ain't putting me in with your
nonsense okay
because where were you where were you
when people of color needed you
where were you where were you you
weren't trying to help me
no you were helping the white male comic
that's who you were helping
that's what you were standing behind
that's what you were trying to like you
were trying to get with that's what you
were trying to support and prop up
you weren't there for me so i'm tired of
you blumping me all in with everyone now
tired of that all right
that's my rant on that
that made me feel better all right so
now we're back to real world advice
from a grown ass man
let's go to it um all right so i got
quite a few of them this week no videos
because nobody wanted to send a video
but first one up what do you think the
value of college is
today what do i think the value of
college is today well i see that in
question implies that
like are you saying that like you know
people with a college degree aren't
getting great jobs or like what is what
what do you value the college
see i think the value of learning
learning is like we've we've
gotten away from that we've gotten away
from just like hey go out and get as
many degrees as you can uh
if it's affordable or or go you know go
out for learning for the sake of
learning go out for the learning to
enhance
who you are as a person physically
spiritually emotionally
educationally if that's a word you know
you're learning how getting a great
education there's nothing wrong with
that and having that degree
does it already statistically proves
that you know you're still in a better
position
so i think a college degree is still
very valuable if you have the ability to
go out and go to college if
if it doesn't hinder your lifestyle say
per se if
if you can swing if you have parents
that are supportive or if you can like
work through college if you can like i
don't think there's anything wrong with
that i think it's still
very valuable even if at the end of that
you don't necessarily get the job that
you want or you're not in the field that
you want
that experience of having all that
you're a more well-rounded individual
ed there's nothing wrong with education
there's nothing wrong with being a
sponge and learning and learning and
getting you know there's nothing wrong
with that it's great i mean we we all
should
find a way to like you know read more
and research more and study more but you
know we're in this like google it world
you know so sometimes it feels like
what's the point of going to get um
memorizing knowledge and getting all
this uh when you could just
you could you could just get all this
information on on your own on the
internet even with like online colleges
and stuff like that so
maybe it's just like we need to change
the focus of what
the educational system is more practical
stuff
uh you know like the practical use of
this information that we're learning
that's probably the part that needs to
change
that's the part that needs to um we you
know it's gonna it's probably been
altering now for the past 20 years
with the influx of like just the the
ability to grab
as much information that we can right at
our fingertips right in our screens so
i think there is still a great value in
the college education today so
yeah no one likes my mates girlfriend
except him do we tell him she's terrible
or leave it
man i've been here i'm one of my buddies
my buddies he married
he married this one everybody hated her
she just was
mean she was a mean person for whatever
reason
she was mean to everybody you know we
just we never got along
you know and so it's just it's just one
of those things what do you do
i mean that it's just a tough spot
because on one hand
like if they're just if how long have
they been together you know if they just
got together
it's yeah you go to your dude like yo
man she's kind of
rotten or something's up with her she
doesn't seem to and then you guys
you know if you maybe you can work it
out with him you know maybe if you're
the kind of group that you all hang out
all the time then it's a moment to be
like
hey what's up with your girl she don't
seem to like me can we figure this out
but if they've been together like years
and then you're coming up with you
haven't liked her this whole time it's
like well hey man what are you supposed
to do at that point
at that point you know you know your
friend's in he's in deep he loves her
there's nothing you could do
my buddy i remember he was breaking up
off and on with this woman and then i
you know and you every time you break up
you go man i know i don't know why you
with her
what'd you you know man i and you guys
are coming here commiserating with him
he's like feeling like yeah i know man
i'm sorry and all this stuff
and then like two weeks later he's like
you like where you at oh i'm out with
so-and-so and you like what
after that happens like two or three
times you got to just be like
hey this ain't on me anymore this is
what he wants that's his life
go do it go do your thing
you know and then you just have to be
like you just have to like deal with it
you know your friend has to just make
time for you and you just have to
tolerate whatever that
is but if it's early on then i do say
that try to work it out you know
respectfully lovingly compassionately be
like
because if you like him and you want to
hang out with him and she's always there
then you need to find a way to work that
out uh if not
then you know it's you're just going to
be miserable and what's going to happen
is you're going to be distancing
yourself from your friend so you have to
ask like what you really want in that
situation
that's uh what i think about it all
right this one i'm second guessing my
major
and feel lost i thought i would have
this figured out
uh the guy said another question so he's
like older actually older meaning for
college i think he's in his 30s but
you know people always second guess
their major i mean
i i mean this is what i think is
what the the system is missing is
for people when they're younger high
school
grammar school those those ages they
need to have more career days again
there need to be
an influx of information into the high
school
for these high school kids to you know
be able to experience or at least be
able to
um be touched by so many different
professions and so they can in their
mind start to be like ooh i think i want
to be that
from that point so i think that you know
we need to like hope that younger people
start
to be like hey i'm interested in this at
a young age or in a high school age
what are you starting to be interested
in and hopefully then you go oh i think
i want to
pursue that and then they go out and
then they go to college
and then maybe they find out why they're
there that oh this isn't really for me
and that's the time where you go oh you
know what i don't like this i actually
like this
so it's really just like i say it's we
got to just experience more things
so we can actually you know
the more options you have the better it
is for you to be like oh okay
you know i really like this but uh this
one has these benefits this one has
these benefits and then you can like
actually make it a choice that makes you
feel inspired it's hard to be inspired
so like if you
if you pick a major and you think oh you
put all your eggs in that basket like
this
is it and then you get there and you
start to go oh man i don't really like
this
just listen there ain't nothing wrong
with that okay
you just you don't like it so get out
while you can
shift pivot try to pivot or if it's
something that you go
or if it's something like oh you know
what i should finish this
because this is going to lead to a
steady career
then if you're making a practical choice
like that then think about that too
but look if you're at a point now where
you're like oh man
i mean like he says you know i'm second
guessing you know if you're second you
know
i talked about this last episode life is
a lot of times about
making a choice and living with it you
know
and the the biggest part about it is the
living with it part
that's the part right there so you know
you know
what are you second guessing because if
you're thinking about are you thinking
about other things
are you thinking about like well i
really am thinking about this major so i
don't know if this
if that's the case or are you saying i
don't know if this one's good enough
no no you made the choice make that good
enough
make it the the path give that path your
all
that's the hard part about it is like
accepting that
so listen i hope you find your way i
hope you figure that out and
uh good luck all right next one
help me says i quit my job i don't know
why i can't
i can't when i no longer want to be
there what is it i mean uh
you know that's called fear to me
he didn't word that the wording is
terrible but i still using it
because it made me start to think about
you know i always get this question when
i'm
um you know on the road radio stations
hey when you start doing comedy why and
why did you wait or whatever
and i always say like it's like you know
we're we're controlled by fear
you know we that's the oftentimes why we
don't make a big choice or we don't
um bet on ourselves or we don't you know
because we're we're being
you know we're a slave to like a too
expensive apartment
or we're a slave to a job that we don't
really like but we need that income
we're in relationships that we don't
really want to be
in but we you know you're afraid to be
alone
there's so many you're you're worried
about money you're you know your
fear that you're not good enough and
that's why you don't go out and change
professions or
that's why you don't go on and hey let
me go take that you know
class that's going to get me that
certification for me to do this or
that's why you don't start doing
stand-up comedy or chasing after being
an actor or trying to do
anything that that you're dreaming about
is fear fear
fear so you know it's like
we've just forget to set up a plan look
if you're at a job that you hate you
hate your job and you just keep
complaining about it
why why don't you just leave well you
don't you there are reasons why you
don't just leave because you're like
well i need to pay my rent
so then therefore before you can leave
your job you need to make sure you have
money saved
before you leave your job you mean you
need to make sure you have another job
set up
if you don't you don't think you're
qualified for another job then now you
know what you have to do now so now i
gotta work backwards i still have to be
able to pay my rent
i need a job that i'm qualified for let
me go get those qualifications
i mean it's just about planning it's
about planning it's about setting
yourself
up for success then you can leave your
job you all
can everybody can leave their job and
find something new you just have to
believe
it's not even just about believing that
you can it's about setting yourself
up making sure that you have all the
steps in place and once you start to do
that you start to realize oh it's not as
hard as i thought it was you know
actually i can do this so what you
should first step you should do is
look into it whatever job you have
looking to move into a different job
that that's a similar place or
or different profession but it has some
of the same skills that you have that
they need
start looking into that and you'll be
surprised how you're like oh man
actually
i can do this and then you're gonna
start to understand that it really isn't
just about being scared
it's just about being like oh man i
don't have it within me to uh
oh is am i going to fail the oh man
maybe i won't make enough money or
oh this is going to be too hard like all
that stuff is fear
you know and when you let fear control
you when you let fear dictate
your actions you're going to be stuck at
a job that you hate
so work on that good luck
how do i d how do i deal with the seven
year itch going into my 14th year of
marriage
well i mean i think this is like listen
i've never been married
so i don't know if i'm the whole person
qualified enough for this
but still these are the kind of things
where it sounds like
you know i already know relationships
are hard you know
the people say oh my relationship's
easier right no i know relationships are
challenging when i say hard i mean like
it's challenging and it should be you
know you're two different human beings
and you're living together and you have
kids and you know there's a lot of
factors that are going on you have your
own
emotions and feelings and the things
that make your
the job makes you feel the things that
this other person makes you feel you
know
and so that stuff becomes hard you know
if you're starting to wander it's like
maybe it's time to like rekindle the
fire within your own relationship you
know
maybe it's time to have date nights
maybe it's time to like hey let's go on
a romantic vacation
let's go on um you know you know what i
mean
let's let's start doing some hobbies
together let's start getting with other
couples and like you know doing game
nights and like you know you have to
make it fun again you have to
find that thing the evolve into whatever
it is going to be now but to be out
there being like
i need to you know be with someone else
i mean that's
that's a selfish choice and it's neither
here nor there in terms of like whatever
you decide but just own that
just own that oh i'm you know because
when you start to feel that hey we all
feel it it's okay to feel something it's
just acting on it that
puts you in a bad place uh puts you down
a dark path
so i just think that instead of like you
know scratch it with the person that
you're with
in different ways you know you know that
you know just
continue to talk and be open and you
know we just get so stale and stagnant
in a relationship that we just kind of
go oh well this is the you know this is
my partner and
you take it take it for granted
don't take it for granted reinfuse some
romance
back into that marriage you owe it to
both of yourselves
good luck all right this is the last one
and this one was like this one got to me
a little bit too because it said
how do you support a rape victim who's
also your girlfriend that's not your
girlfriend it's complicated but
but uh mutual like listen i totally get
what this is about
you know something that's staggering to
me and even though and like what i
talked about earlier on my rant
again i want to say i don't condone bad
behavior at all
all right and what i was talking about
earlier is basically saying
the tools that a person has don't put
those on trial
all right but how someone uses those
tools
that can be put on trial but don't put
the tools on trial
so i don't condone bad behavior so and
you know it really is shocking to me
i don't know how many people have like
female friends or if you have sisters uh
you know yeah
you know even like i know some guys out
there with your wives and girlfriends
you know
when you start to talk you get you have
these vulnerable talks and you start to
hear
from your girl some experience that she
had where you go
damn that happened to you like it's a
staggering amount of women who have
experienced some sort of sexual assault
some
sort of sexual misconduct and it's like
so what you're talking about right now
is a trust
issue man it's about trust how do you
support
someone who's been a victim of that her
trust has been broken
and in so many ways because you know if
it's like some sort of stranger
you know some sort of str if it was a
stranger you know that's terrible
you know and that's a different kind of
mistrust of like just people in general
and just
men in general like i don't want to be
near any man because you know
but then also the the even worse or you
know
on the same level of terrible you know
is somebody that she knew
you know like a date rape or or
you know a family member or you know so
it's all like
broken trust you know broken trust
and you have to try to rebuild that
trust
and help let her know that she's safe
and that's on her to let you know
like you know it's on her timeline so
all you could do
is just be there for her with no
pressure
that's the thing too and you can do
certain things to help her with that
like for instance you know
if you are intimate with her and you
guys have this intimate you know
some if you're already intimate with her
then she already has some trust with you
but if you feel like there's still like
some things there
you need to let her know that sometimes
that there's no pressure for her to have
sex with you
like zero pressure at all like in for
something like
you like you should be able to give her
a full body massage
she could be butt ass naked and she
don't have to do anything
for you all right this is just strictly
for
her look up yoni massage by the way
that's what that is too the only massage
is like
for the totally for the females pleasure
just her
you know like that you have to ask
like you know you start off with a full
body massage and you know you're it's
all about her pleasure
and then when you go down to like the
sensitive private areas it's all about
asking like hey is it okay if i do this
would you like this can i do this and
then it's them being
in complete and utter control that's
what she has to feel
she has to feel that she has complete
control over the situation that she has
complete
trust in you that when she says no
you're going to stop then when she
that you know what i mean and that she
can finally be vulnerable again and
and just again have trust and not be
scared of
certain situations it's a very touchy
situation and
and i like the fact that you're like you
it seems that you're trying to be
sensitive to it and you know reach out
and let her know
and that's what you all you could do you
can't just reassure her with with of
um words it's with actions too that's
what i'm saying
so if you are already intimate with her
it's like hey rub her feet and that's
all that it is hey let me rub your feet
you know you tend to you've been working
all day i'm gonna
give you a foot rub and that's it you
don't do anything else you know
you don't you don't you don't it like
like not everything has to lead to
sex uh let her know that that's by
showing her that that's the situation
you know that you you could cuddle
without it turning into something that
you could
you know all these kinds of things
because it's important for someone like
that to rebuild that trust in herself
we build that trust in men we build that
trust in you know society as a whole
you know it's it's hard you know so i do
wish you
uh good luck with this and listen you
know um
when i do this segment real world advice
from a grown-ass man it's just me giving
my thoughts my common sense takes on the
world
um you know some if i'm not a
professional and i don't claim to be
so you know i like to say this
practically every episode but
if you are feeling if you are struggling
out there with feelings of depression
and anxiety
uh i do highly recommend that you seek
some professional help
professional help is not uh it has a bad
stigma
and by the way they're not necessarily
there to help you fix your problems but
help you
understand them help you navigate
through these feelings because this
person is a professional has seen it
before
and can see the signs and help you guide
you through this
emotional forest that you're like
why do i feel this way how do i feel
this way help you find the origins and
help you like
because when you when you learn those
facts like even someone who's a victim
of sexual assault may not even
understand that
that they're scared that they don't that
that oh i i mistrust
now i know i mistrust because of this so
now they can maybe they can see it
better so
you know going to therapy is not a
terrible thing and i i do highly
recommend it
um you know i know it's like sometimes
for some people it's a financial issue
and so you look like the
the affordable care act is out there
look into it in your state and you'd be
surprised and then there's a lot of like
now because of covet there's a lot of
online stuff now too
and some of that stuff is actually more
affordable than you think so
and if you are having issues there are
hotlines and things to reach out to and
i do highly recommend you do that
but for the most part um a lot of this
stuff is just
uh you know simple simple things that
you just
trying to get a friend i'm being your
friend right now asking your friend for
their opinion and that's really what it
is uh
you know i should call it grown man
opinions uh but you know so that's all
that that is right now but anyways guys
i just i really thank you for watching
uh roofing with griffin so please and
listening to few people that just
listened i don't know
not everybody watches youtube but most
some of you are on spotify and apple
podcast and stitcher and
all the different places that you listen
thank you for listening i truly
appreciate it
uh you know share subscribe and do all
that stuff that
helps the podcast grow i'm continuing
well this is me now this is how i'm
doing my podcast
i do have a few uh guests i'm gonna have
sprinkled in
um you know by the way for those for the
people that uh are regulars on the
podcast i'm gonna be on steve
stevie weeby's show steve and i talked
it out and we're real we're good again
uh good as we could be
right you know and so so look out for
that i'm also going to bring steve on
my podcast that's always a fun time
talking to that guy
so i appreciate you guys again listening
and
you know i'll see you next week
[Music]
you